welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of boba fett episode 4 the gathering
storm which promises to gather a storm
that's probably going to include the
mandalorian dinjarin the will mando join
a guy who slaughters a biker gang after
their crimes were just cast in doubt and
forgets that he didn't leave his armor
and is still alive starlack as always
this episode was filled with interesting
star wars lore and details that you
might have overlooked so i'm gonna break
it all down for you we open back in the
back duh boba's head and torso are now
almost completely healed compared to
previous sessions and now there are
fewer particles swirling around in that
water meaning the healing process is
pretty much complete we learned that
these bubble baths were repeated healing
sessions for the scars from the
sarlacc's digestive acid however what
about the scars on the inside
let me take longer
yes the true reason boba takes these
bats is to try to heal those inner
wounds to process the pain of the family
that he lost the gotcha that he wanted
that he will now have to recreate
because one can only go so far without a
tribe we flashed back to boba right in
his bantha recovering from losing those
tuscan friends now in the 1977 star wars
the banta was actually an asian elephant
named margie who contrary to some
popular belief did not actually wear the
bantha costume backwards and walk in
reverse as hilarious as that image would
have been but rather margie's trunk was
actually just covered by designing a
bantha beard made of horse hair but
because we're nicer to elephants now
thank god the bantha on this show is
actually a full prop that's operated by
four puppeteers and another four people
on remote controls which is why we can
now see it chewing and licking its lips
its tongue actually a separate piece of
that puppet as we saw with the multiple
puppeteers who operated jabba the hutt
they ride past a skeleton of another
bantha we actually saw another bantha
skeleton on the way to mos pogo in the
mandalorian chapter 9 and both of these
evoke that skeleton of the lesser krait
dragon that threepio and r2 passed in a
new hope setting up boba in this episode
to leave nothing rotting in the sun of
tatooine boba creeps up on the backside
of jabba's palace which is now an
opening in the rock wall we haven't seen
this yet we've only seen the front side
whereas this back gate lowers into the
ground as opposed to raising up because
this is the shuttle bay where boba's gun
ship is he later tells finnic help me
recover my fire spray gun ship now yes
lucasfilm is reportedly renaming the
slave one but to clear this up its new
name is not fire spray fire spray is the
class of ship it's a fire spray 31 class
patrol and attack craft we still don't
know what its name is they may just call
it the fire spray because that's the
type of ship it is but it's not like he
named it fire spray like forest named
his ship jenna so i love this shot where
we cross dissolve from tattoo means two
sons to its three moons these are named
gumrasin guermessa and chanini we see
these three because on this night boba's
tribe grows from two him and his trusty
bantha to three with finnick shand after
sharing his roasted scurrier with that
bantha boba spots these lights over the
ridge
[Music]
ah that was ludwig joranson's flute
theme from the mandalorian and these
lights we see are the flash charges that
denjarin and toro caligan detonated to
blind finnick shand in the mandalorian
chapter 5 when toro cruelly shot finnic
and left her for dead here they actually
reused that shot from chapter 5 where
boba fett stepped up to her but the
sound mixing has changed
[Music]
see before they hinted this was boba
fett with the beeps of his armor and the
spur sounds on each of his steps but now
since boba doesn't have his armor on
they removed those beeps and really just
hinted at the spurs on only one of his
steps even though it made no sense that
boba fett had spurs before because he
wasn't writing anything and now it makes
total sense for him to have spurs
because he's riding a pack animal oh
well he takes her to a mod parlor near
mos eisley where those mod youths led by
trash must have gotten their cybernetic
upgrades and we learned they are called
mods just like the 60s gang in the uk
was called but also an abbreviation of
their modified status clever now the
arch over the door is marked with some
oramesh letters i see m-e-r-a followed
by p-l-a the inner arch is actually
graffiti drawing of a crate dragon
skeleton now the graffiti to the right
are the letters u-m-w-e-l-t
which i think just could mean um well
thank ferric i'm wasting my time doing
this but actually as he comes in through
the doorway on the right in red the
graffiti translates to i think mod bod
at least this makes sense because people
in this clinic are getting modified
bodies now inside this clinic there's
some glowing lung implants on the right
and on the back wall is a torso of a
protocol droid actually the concept art
for this location that plays during the
credits shows an imperial probe droid
hanging over the operating chair and a
dismantled golden protocol droid head on
the wall now the mod artist is played by
steven thundercat bruner from suicidal
tendencies the music we are playing in
this parlor is one of his baseline riffs
and he has this clampy right hand this
is actually taken from a super battle
droid this surgeon completes the new
steampunky guts that we saw in the
mandalorian chapter 14 and he explains
he leaves it exposed as some kind of mod
pride
cover all that beautiful machinery just
an interesting statement considering
people like luke skywalker at first
covered up his mod prosthetic but when
we returned to him in the last jedi he
left that machinery exposed which i have
always felt could have been a
realization he later came to years after
he saw his father hid his cybernetic
implants thinking he had to mask his
weaknesses boba crack soap and a black
melon for finnick releasing a tiny
little spray of mist in that dry desert
air we've actually seen these throughout
the series they originated in a 2015
comic story line in which obi-wan kenobi
found them bitter but their milk safe to
drink because the tuscans would drink
from them boba says it takes some
getting used to
the time you start to crave it god ain't
that true for everything i think boba's
referring to his tuscan friends they
took some getting used to but now he
craves their company boba explains i was
rescued by the sand people i tried to
help them instead i got the massacre by
nectar speed bikers speed bikers
defeated tuscans
that's highly unlikely it's interesting
how bobo refers to them as sand people
here and it's finnick who uses the term
tuscans but i just think boba has been
alone with them communicating via hand
signals and now he's talking to a bounty
hunter that he assumes would use their
slur but she surprises and corrects him
passing his little test and yeah then it
casts doubt on the kenton striders truly
being the ones who killed the tuscans
showing that she respects the tuscan's
combat skills but despite this later in
the episode boba straight up vengefully
slaughters those neuto's anyway and
fennec does not object still i think
fenix line here suggests someone might
have set up those nikdos someone like
the pikes or the hutts someone those
criminal overlords are associated with
and yeah i love how this whole
conversation takes place as boba leads
against the belly of that snoring bantha
meaning those puppeteers had to push and
retract this fur against tamer morrison
throughout the take if you think about
it this bantha was the last heartbeat
that boba still has from his tuscan
tribe and that tribe lives on through
him in the scene thenic uses this drone
that looks like a more compact version
of the probe droid that the empire used
to track the rebels on hoth on empire
the orabesh on its screen first
translates to ghost before switching
into several alternate letters ghost may
be finnick's nickname for this and now
it's disguising its chain code to make
it harder to scan and trace back to her
as it zips in through the gate in the
foreground on the right we see the
counterweight lowering to raise the gate
showing how finnick later triggers that
gate back open boba says then i'm gonna
kill that bloated pig who double-crossed
me bit fortuna as far as we know never
directly betrayed boba fett unless maybe
boba blames bib for entangling boba in
that sale barge disaster but finnick is
skeptical you want a headache yes gatra
is a sanskrit term from hindu culture
referring to lineage or a dynasty in the
mandalorian chapter nine gore koresh
swore by the gotra that there was
mandalorian on tatooine and there was a
droid gotcha in star wars literature
referring to a group of droids who
supported droid rights so what would
boba's gotra be what is the house of bet
well bubba belongs to a few lineages
genealogically as a clone he is
connected to all other django clones on
kamino including omega from bad patch
but django singled out boba as this one
clone to bring up as a son later giving
him his armor and allowing boba to
inherit his mandalorian chain code and
ancestry but also boba now has his found
families of the tuscans and the
disaffected criminals and bounty hunters
of tatooine it'd be interesting to see
him forming a gotra of all of these
links that he has and the probe droid
returns and maps out the palace interior
i love how we only see the line of sight
that the droid was able to scan so just
the front surface of the gun ship the
rest is left incomplete because it was
never scanned just cool production
design detail there i love this as
fennick cuts the bars listen closely
yeah that squeaky cinch is the same
sound effect from when anakin seared off
dooku's head in revenge of the sith
and fennec will use this weapon the same
way on the chef now to stay focused on
all these details you got to cut through
the noise and the distractions but if
you want to cut through food you need a
good knife and that's where kamikoto
comes in handy kamikoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from japan their
knives are used by michelin star
restaurants around the world they only
use premium steel sourced from mills in
japan and each kamikoto knife is
individually inspected after a 19 step
process which makes them so confident in
their knives that each one comes with a
lifetime guarantee each knife comes in
this beautiful ash wood box that keeps
the knife stored safely and makes the
kamikoto knife a great looking gift they
offer a wide range of japanese steel
knives from big cleavers down to steak
knives and they have a bunch of knife
sets so you'll have the proper blade for
any occasion one i want to single out
here is the nikiri knife the nikiri
knife has a comfortable handle feels
well balanced and is perfect for
chopping vegetables so guard your gourds
cover your cucumbers protect your
pineapples i'm ready to slice and dice
them i should not play with this because
it is incredibly sharp and super
effective i love this knife and kamikoto
is offering our viewers an extra 10 off
on any purchase with discount code nrs
so just head on over to kamikoto.com
nrs in that kitchen that chef is a ceo
cook droid first seen an attack of the
clones on that liner that anakin and
padme took to naboo meanwhile the sous
chef is an ev series supervisor droid
but probably not ev929 from return of
the jedi since he was confirmed to be
working in chalmun's cantina in the
mandalorian around the same time this
guy bonks a one-eyed frog back into the
pot i love how the chef droid spins his
knives just like general grievous does
with lightsabers while fighting obi-wan
and revenge of the sith now the rat
catcher is an lep series servant droid
which originally dated back to concept
art for phantom menace and later
appeared throughout clone wars this
little guy has antenna-like cat ears
that perk up as he
and then listens literally says huh his
mouth drops open in fear boba swipes at
that red catcher knocking over the
boiling pot so those frogs can escape
and after crawling over that grill you
can hear that droid shuckling in victory
but then after boba captures him this
droid sobs in shame and shuts himself
down
now in that shuttle bay we see a
four-legged gonk droid lumbering past
finnick later shoots this guy to blow
him up this wave of guards are weak ways
and one of them screams at fennick
yes sleemo the hutty's slur that we
heard back in episode 1
and from anakin's potty mouth banana
menace just granny doe pot slamo now in
the gunship cockpit the controls are all
in the mandola language and in the upper
corner that symbol is mandoa for the
letter o maybe for the bay door being
open boba knocks the gunship into a park
skiff this either is the same exact
skiff or the same kind of skiff that
luke and the others escaped on in return
of the jedi after phoenix shoots the
gate mechanism i love how the loading
doors just close on her self-assured
close-up like that lucasfilm shutter
wipe transition on her when she first
pitched this plan earlier so they catch
up to that nikto biker gang as we saw
before their vests have their skeleton
sigil and the word tatooine on the back
but the number two of this group has the
name of slf written in orbish on his
shoulder and i love how boba's shift
begins as just an unnoticeable dot in
the sky until it just looms larger and
larger into view in wrecks all of them
he even reserves a missile to take out
the leaders just to be sure and then he
returns to the sarlacc pit that's where
i was trapped all those years ago first
off it's easy to lose track of this
show's timeline since it jumps between
two periods but this moment is set
during the events of the mandalorian
season 1 which is around 9 aby five
years after returning the jedi which
would mean that boba actually spent five
years with the tuscans now bubba assumes
his best car armor is still inside the
sarlacc even though he seemed at least
semi-conscious when the jawas took it
from him outside the sarlacc but one way
you could see this is maybe that stomach
acid was just so painfully burning
scalding the skin that it felt like his
armor was completely off him the moment
he passed out in the days either way you
can forgive him for getting confused
here i'll also say that it is surprising
to say the least to see the sarlacc
still alive considering it totally
seemed like boba was burning and clawing
his way out of its stomach lining we did
see one of the starlock tentacles lay
lifeless on the sand but that probably
really was the one that han shot to free
lando it just seems like bubba probably
just went up through the sarlacc's mouth
and sarlacc's more resilient than we
thought maybe this one's got his own big
back to tank that he spends all day
taking bubble baths in thinking about
his tragic past we all shut ourselves
and that starlock beak lunges at them
then they freeze herself and releases a
seismic charge
fire in the hall
just like the ones that jango fett
released on ob1 and asteroid belt attack
of the clones it even has that same
delay sound effect
now fenix says the major domo is giving
them intel oh he's singing like a yazoo
yes yizms are the species of joe yaoza
the singer added to the max rebo band in
return of the jedi 1997 special edition
back at garcia whip sanctuary black
chrysanthe glares at some gambling
transitions why is he so mad well
remember trans oceans do have a history
of hunting wookies their later doc
strassie presented a wookie pelt as
tribute to boba in episode one by the
way bk is played by carrie jones a
longtime costumer on major titles i love
his physicality in this role here as the
rage builds the camera does a dolly zoom
which is a camera move for mountain
hitchcock showing raw attention building
in a character garcia flip tries to calm
everyone down recalling bk's time as a
gladiator in the fighting pits and she
says in this civilized place in these
more civilized times almost evoking the
way obi-wan described the galactic civil
war era as an uncivilized period by
saying the time before was more
civilized an elegant weapon
but a more
civilized day but bk ain't interested
even after getting offered to clear his
bar tab so he rips off the train ocean's
arm recalling exactly what han solo
warned threepio a wookie would do it's
cause a droid don't pull people's arms
out of their sockets when they lose
wookies are known to do that and then i
like how max rebo starts playing right
after just like the most eisley cantina
band did right after an amputation
occurred there boba offers bk a job and
bk accepts because these two did used to
work together back as bounty hunters
both working under darth vader and so
back in the palace they gather the other
bosses like the five families of the
godfather including that klitsu indian
boss played by phil lamar coming back
after voicing the pike leader last
episode now i like how the initial scene
geography shows the throne empty on the
surface to signal to the bosses that
boba is not above them he's seated
alongside them at the table but this
also means that this table is situated
above the rancor pit the lep droid
returned so thank god this little cutie
didn't permanently off himself but also
what was he doing here were there rats
scurrying around this dinner table back
to work boba proposes that if the bosses
won't help him fight off the pikes that
they at least remain neutral in the
conflict they appear to agree but we
will see infinix says credits can buy
muscle
if you know where to look
[Music]
ah yes the music there is once again the
flute theme music of the mandalorian din
jarren suggesting finnick will turn to
him as the hired muscle and pedro pascal
may join the series now we should note
that din jaren is not himself a full
army but he does wield the dark saber
appointed contention with bo katan who
wanted the dark saber herself to unite
the scattered mandalorian clans in order
to take back mandalore you think about
it an alliance with boba fett combining
the strength of the mandalorian warriors
to free tatooine from the pikes could
really be the first step toward that
ultimate goal of retaking the throne of
mandalore which they could then cash in
the favor from boba fett using the help
of his combined resources as this
mini-series points us to the mandalorian
season 3. it's just not clear yet if
it'll ultimately be just the pikes that
they face or a more fearsome enemy that
the pike's answer to because one final
detail is hidden in the music that comes
at the end of joseph shirley's book of
boba fett theme song
[Music]
yeah that music definitely parallels
john powell's theme for the crimson dawn
that we heard in solo's star wars story
[Music]
and since maul died shortly before the
events of a new hope kira is now running
the crimson dawn and with her maul
taught lightsaber skills of terrace
cassie she would be a fearsome opponent
for whatever darksaber wielder that she
would face you can support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
me rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you